hey this is presh to Walker here's the
fun geometry problem
three Circles of equal size are placed
in a triangular shape and they are
pairwise tangent
an elastic band is placed around the
three circles
the height from the top of the top
circle to the bottom of the bottom two
circles is exactly two meters
the question is what is the length of
the elastic band
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so here's how we'll solve the problem
we will first solve for the length of
the radius of each circle and then we
will get an expression for the length of
the elastic band in terms of r
to get started construct the center of
each circle
then connect the centers of the circles
this will form the shape of an
equilateral triangle
construct a radius from the top of the
top Circle to its Center
then drop this down to an altitude of
the equilateral triangle and extend it
down to the bottom horizontal line
segment
now suppose each circle has a radius
that's equal to R then each side of the
equilateral triangle will have a side
length that's equal to 2R
this length will also be equal to R
now here we have half of an equilateral
triangle so one angle will be 60 degrees
the other angle will be 30 degrees and
we have a special 30-60-90 right
triangle
so the length of the longer leg will be
equal to R root 3.
so we've now calculated the distance
from the top to the bottom will be equal
to R plus r root 3 plus r and we were
given this is equal to 2 meters
we can simplify this equation to get R
multiplied by two plus root 3 is equal
to 2 and that means R is equal to 2
divided by two plus root 3.
so we solve for r
we will now form an expression for the
length of the elastic band in terms of r
to do that we'll calculate the lengths
of these straight line segments of the
elastic band and the curved portions of
the elastic band
so first let's do the straight line
segments
so first construct this radius which
will be tangent to the straight line
segment of the elastic band do the same
thing for the other side we now have a
rectangle for this side of the
equilateral triangle we can do the same
thing for the other two sides of the
equilateral triangle
now each angle in a rectangle is equal
to 90 degrees so we have 90 degrees here
and here
now if we go all the way around we have
360 degrees for the circle so we can
subtract 90 degrees 60 degrees and 90
degrees to be left with 120 degrees
this will be true for the other two
central angles as well
so now let's calculate the straight line
segments of the elastic band
each side of the equilateral triangle
has a length equal to 2R and if we
extend this out we see that these line
segments are each equal to 2R
we now need to calculate the length of
the curve portion which will be the
length of a circular Arc
so here we have a circular sector the
same thing is true over here and also
here
so the length of each of these circular
arcs will be one third of the entire
circle because we have a central angle
of 120 degrees which is one third of 360
degrees
so each of these circular arcs will be
one-third of the circumference which
will be one-third of two pi r
so we'll have the same length for all
three of these
we now have an expression for the length
of the elastic band in terms of r
so just add up all of these lengths we
have two R plus two R plus two R plus
two pi r over three plus two pi r over
three plus two pi r over three
this will be R multiplied by 6 plus 2 pi
but we know that R is equal to two
divided by 2 plus root 3 so substituting
in and simplifying we get 12 plus 4 Pi
all over 2 plus root 3 and this is
approximately equal to 6.58 meters and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time
foreign